el distrito transgénero de san francisco
es conocido históricamente por acoger a
los recién llegados y también a los que
a veces caían en los márgenes de la
sociedad
sofía es una mujer transgénero mexicana
que lleva dos años viviendo en este
distrito aunque afirma que el barrio a
veces puede ser complicado está feliz
esto es un paraíso y si está atrayente a
muchas mujeres y una de ellas soy yo
podría decirse que yo estoy una y soy
una inmigrante mexicana que vivía en
carolina del norte y tuvo que
trasladarse san francisco para poder
luchar por mis sueños poder hacer mi
cambio de nombre y poder conseguir un
estatus en este país la organización
detrás del distrito transgénero lleva
años ayudando a mujeres como sofía a
evitar la discriminación y la
marginalización ayudamos a la gente
transgénero a por ejemplo con este
programa de vivienda que acabamos de
lanzar hace como un mes y ayudamos a
gente transgénero
a poder cambiar su nombre en los
documentos de la corte
contratamos artistas para que hagan a
murales
y diferentes cosas en la ciudad en el
distrito para hacerlo más bello entre
las actividades de esta organización se
encuentra a velar por el bienestar de la
comunidad incluyendo los sintecho
juniper recorre estas calles con las
otras integrantes de la organización una
vez al mes
caminamos por las calles para ver
cualquier cambio en nuestra comunidad
para ver si hay algo nuevo necesidades
que hay que cubrir y cosas así
este barrio alberga a una de las
comunidades más numerosas y densas de
personas transgénero del país en la
última década está habiendo amenazada su
idiosincrasia ante el avance de la
gentrificación